Albany New York is next Anna is with us
hi Anna how are you hi Dave I'm great
how are you better than I deserve what's
up so I'm in an awkward position where I
do janitorial cleaning in an office
building that has multiple practices
inside medical practices so some of my
clients are the individual practices and
then another one of the client is the
landlord of the whole building because
we do the common areas as well now
there's a feud so to speak between one
of the tenants one of the practices and
the landlord both of them are my clients
and both of them I feel loyalty to and I
have a long rapport with them the tenant
illegally changed the locks without
giving a key to the landlord and put me
under explicit direction and instruction
not to let the landlord into the
practice and is accusing the landlord of
illegal activity that I don't really
believe because I just know her and I
just give her the benefit of the doubt I
don't think she's capable of the kinds
of things she's being accused of so I
feel very weird I don't think I can
rightfully tell this landlord that I'm
not letting her in if she needs to go in
and um I don't know if I should just
tell them I'm not cleaning for them
anymore because I don't like being in
this position or what should I do
yeah that's probably what I would do
yeah I don't think you're gonna fix
crazy and this is Chris look right yes a
lot of drama there's a lot of crazy here
and you know you can't be telling
somebody that owns a property that they
can't go in it I mean that's not your
position that's right no that's
ridiculous
yeah I mean only a judge can tell um
that I got to tell you if if I'm a
landlord and they change the locks on my
building I'll evict them yeah that's
what I actually had a conversation with
the landlord about it yesterday and I
was like you're gonna let them stay
after this and then she doesn't seem
like she's about to evict them but she's
you know definitely taking action about
but you know changing the locks and yeah
I mean yeah I'm just not going to have
dramas but people get confused about her
own stuff I own the freaking building so
that well I'm the owner you don't change
the lives on my building yeah I mean
this situation it is a little bit
different because it's actually owned by
a huge corporation and the landlord that
I'm referring to is the one who owns the
leashed who then sublets it to these
small practices so she doesn't actually
own the building well she's the master
she's the master Lee so are in there
they they they likely in their lease to
do they're just playing draw they're
acting like four-year-olds they're
playing drama so honestly I just I would
just hand them all the keys and I go
listen I don't want to be apart of this
y'all are all crazy yeah that's kind of
what I was thinking but I I really
wanted to get here yeah you're not gonna
there's no there's no three or four
conversations you're going to have
that's going to make these people not be
crazy yeah and so you're gonna be
dealing with crazy as long as you deal
with crazy it's just I would let them go
I'd let them go life's too short deal
with crazy and that's what you're
dealing with this is not gonna turn out
well for you you're gonna get put in the
middle they've already put you in the
middle and now you're running back
before trying to be the ambassador to
crazy
don't be the ambassador to crazy it's a
bad assignment this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]